Dennis kucinich,
I grew up in Cleveland,
Ohio,
the oldest of seven children,
and my parents never owned a home.
Uh,
we were renters by the time I was 17.
We lived in 21 different places,
including a couple of cars.
Uh,
that experience of growing up in the
inner city,
which I've outlined in a,
in a book that I've just released called
the courage to survive is an experience
that really had an indelible imprint
upon the way I look at the world and
upon my soul because it,
uh,
it taught me compassion,
what people go through to just try to
make it day to day,
the importance of a job of a healthcare,
being able to put food on the table and
clothes on kids' backs.
The important of education,
um,
you know,
these are all things that are part of
people's practical aspirations and
having been riveted and that experience
growing up in Cleveland,
I understand as someone aspiring to be
president of the United States,
how terribly important all of these
things are for,
for,
for people.
So I'm,
I'm,
my worldview is truly shaped by that
experience and growing up.
And I know the whole world didn't live
in conditions that were near poverty and
I know that.
But I also know that those who do don't
have many spokes persons in government.